this is grand master daniel naraditsky
we are watching the legend gary kasparov
face off against ikaru nakamura at the
saint louis rapid and blitz kasparov
starts with d4 knight f60 caro he likes
the nimzo indian yup we see the nimzo
indian here knight c3 bishop v4
gary taking a look at hikaru there let's
see which line of the nimzo gary chooses
so many different possibilities here for
white queen c2 is what gary has played
for the last couple of years uh in all
of these blitz tournaments but taking a
little bit of time here there's also e3
there's bishop g5 white's got a huge
menu of options hikaru a specialist in
the nimzo indian he's been playing it
for many many years and indeed queen c2
the traditional mainline castles
little little issue there both players
smiling bishop takes c3 queen takes e3
following the main line d5 this is all
normal knight f3 by gary now black
generally takes on c4 in this position
and hikaru does and then plays b6 and
gets that bishop out to a6 attacking the
queen gary with a smile plays h4 and
that is a move that gary has patented
he's played it a couple of times he's
one of the only ones who has made this
move as he continues looking up to
hikaru gauging his reaction ikaro
doesn't seem too amused h4 a dangerous
move white gets started on the attack
white wants to play h5 and h6 because
why not who doesn't want to attack when
all your pieces aren't developed you
carry strikes at the center with c5
following the general rule if there's a
move on the flank you strike in the
center because sparrow takes on c5 is
this a pawn sacrifice i think it is now
is hikaru going to recapture on c5 or is
he gonna play a tempo move such as
bishop a6 no he takes on c5 and now a
big choice for gary gary can grab that
pawn on c5 but then the queen is going
to become really vulnerable and black
can start developing with tempo knight
a6 knight e4 so gary could also make it
developing or he could keep pushing his
h-pawn he could play h5 and threaten to
play h6 and induce a lot of weaknesses
on black's king's side now gary's king
is still in the center it's not very
safe but hikaru hasn't completed his
development so i don't think white's
king is in any imminent danger this
might be a good opportunity to keep
pushing that h-bond gary taking his time
here the third option is to develop with
a move like bishop g5 and gary going for
h5 this is the principled option and now
another dilemma for hikaru does black
allow white to push that pawn all the
way to h6 in that case the dark squares
are going to be so so very weak i think
hikaru has to push his h-bond up to h6
halting the progress of gary's h1 but
you can also play bishop a6 you can put
the emphasis on peace development you
can give a check on a5 that doesn't look
too effective hikaru does go for h6
and once again the same decision for
gary does he take on c5 or is he going
to push that g pawn up because the pawn
on h6 is now a hook if gary can get his
g pun and run it up to g5 that's going
to cause a lot of problems on black's
king's side so hikaru he's going gonna
have to speed it up on the other side of
the board if he doesn't want gary to run
him off the board of the king side
but for now gary taking his time he's
definitely lower on the clock here
you can see the concentration on his
face he's no longer looking up at a car
mumbling to himself there what is he
going to do will he grab that pawn on c5
or will he play g4 and there's the
answer gary going g4 going as principled
as possible he's going for hikaru's
throat and now nakamura he's got no time
to waste because if gary gets g5 in
things are going to get really nasty on
the king's side hikaru could play bishop
a6 he could also bring his queen up to
d5 and offer a trade of queens and he
does
now the thing is gary seems a little bit
surprised by the move the end game isn't
out of the question for white and gary
almost immediately takes the queen yika
recaptures with a knight a little bit
surprised at that i thought maybe taking
with a pawn would have fixed the pawn
structure now black's got this very weak
pawn on c5 and guess what just because
the queens are off the board doesn't
mean that white can't still attack on
the king's side and there gary goes g5
if anything white doesn't have to worry
about the safety of his king anymore i
really like gary's position he's got the
two bishops he's got a lot of attacking
potential on the king side he's moving
with confidence and hikaru still has
that really weak pawn on c5 that he has
to deal with i think black is worse here
this h4 idea by gary it's worked to
perfection but hikaru he is so well
known for his ability to get out of
these situations first of all he's got
to complete his development knight c6
bishop b7 his king queenside pieces are
still on their initial squares how is he
going to arrange those pieces ikaro
twirling the pawn
thinking about how to position things he
goes f6 first he hits the bishop gary
gonna probably drop it back to d2 let's
see hesitating a little bit there he
brings it back to d2 gary certainly
doesn't want to give up either of his
bishops and this idea of playing h5h6
producing more weaknesses on black's
king's side also something that icaro
has to worry about nakamura gets his
night out to c6 now rook c1 looks really
natural gary seems surprised at that
move as well how does he cargo defend
the c pawn after rook c1 maybe that's
what gary's surprised about white can
also play rook g1 and continue to get
things going on the king side no he goes
rook c1 and ikaro going knight d4 that
was his idea so what if gary takes the
pawn on c5 that's gary acknowledging all
right that move it was not such a bad
move yeah but now i can take ball on c5
and i don't really see black's
compensation icaro has a pair of
good-looking knights but
yeah yeah we have a trade on f3 one of
the knights disappears and gary has a
slightly damaged pawn structure but he's
up a healthy pawn he's still got the two
bishops he still has the g file and king
side pressure white is much better here
but can gary convert this into the full
point as he's dropping a little bit low
on time he's got about two and a half
minutes he probably has to get his other
bishop out maybe bishop d3
maybe bishop h3 whoa rook up to h4 with
a move as he activates his rook down the
side and he might bring it over to the
queen side with rook h to c4 he doesn't
want to give up control of any of these
open files
and he carries in trouble here now
hikaru could play rook c8 but then gary
could double up on the c file this is
looking
really dire high doesn't seem too
concerned though he goes rook b8 hitting
the pawn on b2 now the natural move here
is b2b4 maybe he car wants to play a5
and tear open that b file but that would
involve sacrificing another pawn that
looks really dangerous
okay a6 by hikaru slowing down the
progress of gary's pawns not allowing b5
now gary still like bishop c4 here
rook d4 lots of possibilities gary's
gonna have to speed it up a little bit
here hikaru is not someone you want to
get into acute time pressure with he
will produce problems regardless of the
position
gary hesitating a little bit here signs
of anxiety gary can sense that he's
pretty close to winning this game rook
d4 centralizing his rook putting more
pressure on the knight on d5 now he
wants to play bishop c4 and that bishop
on d7 is undefended so hikaru gets it to
b5 that's a nice move and that's why
hikaru played a6 now if gary trades then
the a file opens up and the pawn on a3
is going to be weak i think gary should
play bishop h3 get that bishop away and
that e6 pawn has been left undefended
and gary goes bishop g2 ooh he wants to
push his f1 that's a very interesting
idea he wants to play f3 f4 and
potentially even f5 and soften up the
knight on d5 potentially he could also
take on d5 and trade his bishop in for
another extra pawn so we might see an
opposite colored bishop end game on the
cards with one or two extra pawns for
white gary and almost no risk of losing
this game but can he continue pushing
the gas pedal down let's see hikaru
slows down the pawn with f5 now taking
on d5 here
probably not the wisest idea because
hikaru would recapture with check so
maybe gary should move his king to the
side and then he can take on d5 twice
you could also play bishop e3 to
physically close that e file down
i think that's probably what gary has to
do because otherwise hikaru all of his
minor pieces are protected no other
weaknesses in the position i think
gary's gonna have to take on d5
eventually and try to win that
opposite-colored bishop end game with
two extra pawns
hesitating there and he goes bishop f3
just sort of improving his position
immediately responded with king h7 i
think he's trying to get gary as low on
the clock as possible
gary's got to make a decision here how
is he going to take on d5 he goes bishop
c3
okay maybe he wants to play king d2 i
think he wants to play king d to get the
king off of the e file and he does
hikaru preemptively might be doubling on
the e file
and you know he goes rook d8 okay rook
dia now gary could take on d5 but that
would involve allowing blackstroke to
infiltrate to e2 at the end of the line
so maybe gary has to continue improving
his position looks over at the clock
scratches this here gary back in thought
he's below two minutes now he's got to
make a decision here is he going to take
that knight on d5 and if not how else do
we improve your position hesitating i
think he was about to take it withdraws
his hand back maybe bring the bishop
back to b2 first
white is in no hurry white can continue
improving his position but gary finally
decides to take the knight he takes d5
now is he going to take that pawn on d5
and allow black stroke to access e2 it's
not the most dangerous thing in the
world because white can just drop the
king back to d1 takes on d5 hikaru
doesn't seem too happy now hikaru has a
decision to make is he going to trade
the rooks or does he play rook e2track
first i think black has to trade the
rooks and then go rook e2 check and try
to get as many of white's pawns on the
second rank
as possible maybe take on f2 and then
try to take on f4 this is looking really
really bad though but the pawn on g7
that's being aimed at by white's bishop
and that pawn could be targeted if
white's rook ever gets on a seventh rank
so he car not only is he down two pawns
but he has the potential to lose the
pawn on f5 and also lose the pawn on g7
he might be down three or four pawns in
the blink of an eye so a lot to think
about here for nakamura as he tries to
find a way to save this very very
difficult position what is he going to
do
will he keep the second rook on the
board he could play rook d to e8 but
then gary could close down the e file
with bishop e5 okay he decides to trade
and he goes rook d7 he actually trades
another pair of rooks okay now what a
decision that is now gary up two puns
but can he win this end game opposite
color bishop n games can be drawn even
if one side is down two or even three
pawns so hikaru he has to try to get his
king over to the queen side because what
gary's gonna try to do is create a past
pawn where he has the two on one on the
queen side gary has to get his king
there as quickly as possible
and then try to go a four b5 and create
a password before hikaru can get his own
king to the queen side because the f
pawns are totally futile they're doubled
they're not going anywhere in h6 by gary
he's trying to keep black's king as far
away from the queen side as possible
that makes sense now hikaru could have
played kenji seven but he goes king h5
he goes the other way that's a little
surprising but he goes to the king side
hikaru is trying to take gary's pawns in
the time that gary takes to create a
passer bishop d2 gary has to keep his f
pawns alive because if he doesn't hikara
is going to sacrifice his bishop for the
queenside pawns and gary will have no
pawns left but gary could sacrifice one
of the f pawns and maybe anchor his
bishop to the other one if he could get
his bishop over to g5 he would be
winning because he could rid a pass pawn
you can see gary nervous there he's
trying to calculate he's got not a lot
of time on the clock takes the queen for
fidgeting now hikaru has to decide will
hikaru defend the apon i think he has to
because if gary gets two passers on the
queen side then the game is completely
over so bishop b5 here or bishop c8 i
think is forced and then gary he's going
to try to combine a4 b5 and if he has an
opportunity he'll get his bishop across
the board to g5 in order to anchor it to
the f4 upon this looks winning for white
i don't see how hicario can get both of
white's f pawns i just don't see it in
the king on f3 it's too far away from
the queen side car taking his time here
he doesn't have a lot of it himself he's
approaching one minute on the clock i
think he's got to go bishop b5 he's got
to buy himself as much time as possible
gary's just going to go a4 anyway and
he's going to sacrifice the a4 pawn for
the a6 pawn and then he's going to have
a pass b pawn and that pawn is going to
rumble toward promotion
and if he can leave himself one of these
f pawns then he's going to win hikaru
doesn't see a movie he's down to 45
seconds what is he going to do
you can see him deep in thought the
wheels turning in his brain these end
games are often drawn you can often
build a blockade or a fortress but a
pass pawn is a bishop's worst enemy he
carved down to 30 seconds he's got to
make a move he seems frustrated i don't
think he's finding a way to save the
game bishop b5 and immediately gary
plays a4 dislodging that bishop from b5
doesn't matter hikaru he goes bishop f1
but gary can now play b5 and create a
pass pawn hesitating there you don't
want to play a5 yeah he goes b5 we have
a trade there's that pass pawn car who
takes on up to gary has to keep the f4
pawn alive he has to keep that pawn
alive but now bishop where's the bishop
going to go gary down to 15 seconds what
is he going to do bishop c one kingdom
one but now he emblem should be two he
can get his bishop to g5 oh i think
hikaru that's it i think he's gonna go
bishop e7 bishop g5 and then he's gonna
push the b-pawn and immediately gary
goes for it bishop e7 you can see the
confidence he carver resigns and gary
kasparov with an amazing win against
hikaru nakamura and if you want to watch
more videos like like this click on the
link in the playlist hope you enjoyed
the legend winning another game